to our friend Elon Musk well something
created the universe yeah and he turns
water into white and he makes a story
out of he goes I like party huh
this position human being rejects a
human being being his God red like a
whole bunch of religious books including
the Bible and I'm like there's a bunch
of things now that I didn't teach you at
Sunday school offending
kid I was like I had this existential
crisis and I was trying to figure out
what's the meaning of life let's say you
had one minute less than two minutes to
go ahead and talk with him what would
you throw at him I would just ask him
one thing I would say see Elon you are
so sensible person so so here we have uh
Dr zakira Knight who's talking about
this let's see what he has to say it's
the first time I'm hearing this this
time you actually gave him a copy of the
Quran
foreign
[Music]
the thing you know
[Music]
assalamu alaikum welcome to the D show
and not only are we talking about Elon
Musk do you even got
[Music]
my Paradise Hill fire we're talking
about the Deen the way of life that will
get one to be successful in this life
and Hereafter we got a special guest in
the dean show Studio former or student
of ahmedat he's one of the mightiest
messengers of God We Believe
Jesus we believe in this miraculous
birth which many modern-day Christians
including the Bishops of the Anglican
Church they don't believe today but we
believe that Jesus Christ was born
without a human father Miracle of God's
creation We Believe
we believe that he was a messy the
Messiah translated Christ we believe he
gave life back to the dead by Allah's
permission and he healed those born
blind on the lepers by Allah's
permission
can't you see this is our attitude
towards his mighty messenger of God
Quran of mine Mary the mother of Jesus
is mentioned a hundred percent spend
more time than in your Bible can you
believe it is it believable Mary the
mother of Jesus is mentioned in my book
100 more times than in your book and you
think that we are the enemies
were you a student of zakarnak also ah
mashallah I came into the field of dawa
meeting
Allah and of course Dr Zakir Naik was
once upon a time in India yes so he was
also a major factor of all the dawa
activities back in India long back but
then for me the main motivation was
so you're a official student you would
say that uh you can say this way that I
was working in Saudi Arabia and Riyadh
when Ahmad was hospitalized there for
his lock-in syndrome and he was there
for about eight to nine months and
mashallah I got an opportunity to visit
Ahmad almost daily uh at his hospital
and then I think fourth or fifth day
when I was visiting him his son told me
that you see my father doesn't want you
to just come and waste your time like
this do you do dawa and I was like what
is dawa I said you don't know what is
dhava so they gave me a copy of the
Bible who said they don't want you to
waste time like this his son no his son
says the father doesn't want to check
the Ahmad didn't want so his son what
was the son Muhammad Yusuf yes who was
shot in South Africa unfortunately
yeah he said my father doesn't want you
to come and waste your time like this
daily yeah he wants you to do dawa and I
was like what's dawa I said you don't
know what's Zava you don't see my
father's videos so I said but I've never
experienced it in my life I've never
gone on a stage to do any public show so
he gave me a copy of the Bible he said
come on start memorizing these verses I
said I'm in Saudi Arabia I can't carry a
Bible they said no nothing will happen
just tell them you're a student of Ahmad
you're learning from him so I took it
then I started doing some homework then
they asked me to start memorizing some
ayat of the Quran relevant to dawa and
learn the translation so I would
memorize them come in front of Ahmad
read it out and I make mistakes then
this continued for about one week and
then he said no no only this is not
going to work my father wants you to
give some talks I said I can't give
talks he said then don't come if you
don't want to give talks so but then
that passion was there to meet
so I started preparing small talks on
topics that Ahmad had given so when I
used to give those talks in front of
Ahmad he was in a condition where entire
body was paralyzed and he would only
move his face or laugh or just do some
actions from his eyes so the mistakes I
used to make he used to laugh and then
Yusuf did that used to say you see
you're making my father laugh yeah I
used to actually give talk yeah that's
how he started and mashallah that
practice started to grow and finally
when Ahmad was returning to South Africa
I was working in Toys R Us in Riyadh at
that time and I was on a very good job
uh mashallah but Allah has opened my
heart
and I learned that Ahmad returning to
South Africa so I ask you something that
I want to come to South Africa he said
that my father in a response to a
questionnaire uh in Pakistan once when
he wanted to come to South Africa my
father said that do Dava wherever you
are so masha'allah I realize that I owe
a lot to my country India I was born
there brought up there I was I mean my
parents lived there and my studies were
in India so I owe a lot to my country so
I shall go back to my country to do the
service of Islam to share Islam with the
people there so alhamdulillah resigned
my job came back to India and February 1
1998 I registered a non-governmental
organization NGO by the name Islamic
Research and Educational Foundation with
the acronym as i r e f and since 1998 I
am into this field and alhamdulillah
since about 2004 I have been visiting
the U.S the first time I was invited by
the U.S state Department along with
about 15 to 16 more Scholars of the
Muslim Community from India and then
since then alhamdulillah has been a
routine and masha'allah always visiting
you watching your shows back in India so
now you have become a very popular
person all over the world alhamdulillah
may Allah bless you and it's so
wonderful to hear that you're going to
very soon establish the biggest dawa
Center in India in the USA by the name
the Deen Center
[Music]
our brother Eddie is a brother that I
have known him more than 15 years
he is known about the hour and inviting
the people to this to the dinner a job
that many people cannot do it so Allah
bless him and my message to the Muslim
brothers and sisters in Islam our
brother
Eddie he established a center that will
serve the Muslim Community in the State
of Florida and I'm inviting to everyone
that they should donate the generosity
for the sake of Allah so that Dean
Center in Florida
could continue the tower the brother to
establish a long time ago and and you
know if you do this for yourself and
definitely you will be getting the
reward from Allah
and that Center will be established for
the dawah the dean of Allah so please
donate generously and support our
brother Eddie and may Allah support him
and I ask Allah to make our Deeds
sincere for his sake and may Allah
accepted
foreign
and you become a big source for making
the best
people on earth I always say if you ask
me I would always suggest that Americans
are the best people I have ever met
across in the world alums are very
lovely people so no mashallah you being
from this place I tell the American
Muslims here you see America is a
superpower that the world agrees to so
the Muslims living anywhere in the part
of the world they will feel that
American Muslims are super Muslims so
they have a huge responsibility upon
them and they shall make sure that
American brothers and sisters the
non-muslim brothers and sisters they
they are reached out with the correct
Message of Islam uh the wrong Notions
about Islam are by the Muslims clarified
answered and the people are very
academically approached to in and
invited to Islam mashallah do the job of
the prophets and earn the reward of the
prophets was the statement of my master
Allah he used to say dawa is always the
job of all the prophets Allah sent every
Prophet to do dawa mashallah so
alhamdulillah I think may Allah really
help you for the Deen Center mashallah
very soon I'll be there to give talks at
your Center too inshallah inshallah so
before we go and give some dawah to our
friend Elon Musk an invitation I want to
go ahead and say this is something fresh
that just happened you were on your way
and it's not the first time actually the
last time we spoke you were on your way
and you were in an Uber and you at the
first time you didn't get a chance to
share something with you did share uh
give the Uber Tower some some dawa this
time you actually gave them a copy of
the Quran can you go ahead and paint a
picture how it started the conversation
with the Uber driver and how it ended
that you actually he wanted a copy of
the translation of the Quran basically
uh whenever I travel through Uber or any
of these taxis I make sure that I start
an interaction with the person driving
the car
so when I started speaking to them last
time when I came uh for a cup of coffee
with you at Starbucks
so at that time when the Uber driver was
there I started the conversation with
him I talked to him even he was
interested in taking a copy of the Quran
but somehow he was getting late so he
rushed away but this time uh the
brothers stopped to take a copy of the
Quran so I started the discussion saying
my name is Imran so in response they say
their name so I asked them uh do you
read the Bible so you just you just you
just uh you just came out openly for you
introduce yourself where are you from
yeah sometimes sometimes I tell them you
know I am from India and I'm visiting
here so they say oh lovely that's great
so then then the next phrase you just
said do you read the Bible sometimes I
ask them to read the Bible so they may
ask you know I'm not really did you do
anything else before you opened up with
that no no I I I when I asked this
question then I tell them I'm Imran yeah
so when I ask them do you read the Bible
sometimes they say yes sometimes I don't
sometimes they say not a very uh
frequently so then I say you know my
name has some significance yeah so
what's it so I say Imran was the name of
the father of
oh really we didn't know that so then I
asked them did you know that the Muslims
believe in Jesus and Moses so they say
oh really some say yes we know we have
some Muslim friends who told about that
so then why didn't you discuss with your
Muslim friend how do you believe in
Jesus so I said well no let me be your
friend and let me tell you about Jesus
so then I start talking about Jesus
mother Mary mentioned in the Quran in
the Bible then I start quoting them
references from the Bible so now they
get surprised how are you a scholar or a
teacher what are you so then I tell them
that I'm into public speaking and I came
to this country for the first time in
2004 the U.S state Department had United
me former talks here so they become very
happy oh really that's really great so
then I tell them that do you know Jesus
Christ my peace be upon him he talked
about worshiping the only one God and
you see Jews the Christians the Muslims
we all believe in one God in fact every
human believes that there is one God but
Islam is more specific about identifying
the God so when you say one God one is
not a specific identification so in that
word one you have different images of
God so Islam makes it very clear that
one has to be unique the one has to be
one who cannot be imagined by your
imagination your imagination shall not
capture the almighty God
so then this way the discussion starts
and finally it comes because I am a
Muslim of course no Topic in the
discussion is in I mean complete without
talking about terrorism
did he bring that up or did you no I I
deliberately do it because they feel a
little shy to discuss that subject I say
you see so many Muslims are into
terrorism they say yes we understand
then I start quoting them statistics
from FBI from other sources I say there
is a book dying to win by Robert Pape
from DePaul University do you know he
confesses in the book within extensive
research that the maximum suicide
bombings were committed by non-muslims
around the world he says that he
interviewed those people who failed in
their suicide bombings especially from
Iraq and Afghanistan and when he met
them and he asked they said we did not
do it in the name of religion religion
was not the major factor to do that yeah
so or really is that so so I say yes see
as common human beings you and I we are
at uh lovely understanding towards each
other it is generally a few Rascals of
every society that spoil the entire
fabric of the society that they make
that Society intolerant they have
ideologies which are intolerant and they
spread that intolerance every way so
it's our duty to understand who are
these people and then I talk to him
about how media plays a dirty game and
how it uh damages the image of the
Muslims around the world which has been
unfortunately happening for a very long
time now so he starts listening to me
then I say to him that did you read the
Quran ever in your life the translation
he says no I have never so then I ask
him do you have a habit of reading any
books because I found American people
always holding some book and reading it
whether they are in the train whether
they are in the Metros whether they are
in the streets or at the Starbucks he
said yes of course I read a lot of books
so I said I'll give you an English
translation of the Quran don't tell
consider it don't pre-program yourself
don't become prejudiced that you're
reading Quran just feel that you're
reading a an English book written by
some author yeah and then
keep reading it and you will learn so
many things about Islam directly
first-hand information oh that's
wonderful so is it in the English so
sometimes they are very surprised how
can it be in English so I tell them you
see the Bible that is in English English
didn't exist when Jesus and Moses
existed but what you read in the Bible
is actually the translation of the
original so we have also translations
for the Quran and then by the time we
come to you I know you'll definitely
have translations of Quran so I give you
a call I say I want to give it to
brother and Masha Allah then you send it
down
and so he this is the conversation that
happened at the end he gets a copy of
the I mean it's a very short time you
see it's a very short time in that very
short time uh you can't talk much you
can't just because he's also on his job
yeah so we try to use this opportunity
to the best of our abilities I do the
same thing in Hyderabad when I'm
traveling back or forth from airport to
my home or from my home to the airport I
100 make sure that at least when I'm
coming back from the airport to my
office or my home that the brother has
dropped me shall get a copy of the Quran
so I alhamdulillah try to gift it this
has me thinking because you had Dr
Zucker Nike there was another person out
there we don't have to mention his name
that he was Dr Zucker Nike was
specifically talking to this individual
who was kind of saying something along
the lines that you know this talking to
people well I forgot exactly what he
said in in the lines of um uh it's Dao's
more through just the actions so now you
have a particular situation where you're
an Uber what kind of actions are you
going to do other than speech yeah
you're right Dr zakarnak addressed this
so but I don't know if you know the
scenario with the two no absolutely I
I'm not aware of that but I am aware of
some who say that you shall have good
actions to impress somebody so dawa is
not that important your good actions are
very important I always ask them
who can be better in actions than
Muhammad sallallahu himself the best man
on Earth with the best actions still
Allah commanded him your actions are
very good that's a part of the tablish
of propagation but dawa you have to do
see our people don't understand how
important dawa is because for a very
long time I would say for a very long
time
the Muslims have been programmed in
their home
to practice five times Salah
be obedient to the parents be a good
husband be a good wife be good parents
be good children uh earn Halal I mean
these things are very good I mean there
is no second thought about it but I
always when I do my talks I ask my
Muslim Community my Muslim brothers and
my sisters can you show me one ayat in
the Quran where Allah said o Prophet
Muhammad if you do not perform five
times a day in the sight of Allah you
have not fulfilled your messenger root
so they say no there is no ayat of this
time I say is there in hadees which mama
said if somebody does not perform five
times Salah they have not fulfilled
their job as a Muslim or their mother
said I have not performed my
responsibility as a prophet so they say
no there is no hadees of this time I
said there is one ayat in the Quran I
always try my Muslim brothers and
sisters to memorize the reference
because the reference of this ayat is
very simple you see mostly we have I
mean as a majority we have five fingers
on our hand
so Surah number five of The Glorious
Quran and ayat number is 67 so you see
when you write Surah 5 you put a colon
after that and add 67 numerically five
six seven Come Together Fifth Surah 67th
ayat and what is the ayat Allah is
addressing Mama's law Islam and saying
propagate what has been revealed to you
from Allah
if you do not do this if you do not
propagate this to those who don't
believe
if you don't do this
then for a surety you did not fulfill
messengerhood
Allah says I shall protect you against
your enemies if you do this job
Allah says those who do not do this job
of giving hidayat to others from the
Quran they are in the sight of Allah
like the disbelievers so the very
mission of Muhammad sallam is
propagating Quran to others the whole
Muslim Community has left this today you
see there is a Hadith which
he has taken it in his sahih the prophet
salallahu says that the time will come
in my ummah where
the people of my ummah will make a lot
of duas to Allah and Allah is not going
to accept their duas the reason they
have stopped inviting non-muslims to
Islam meaning talking to non-muslims
about what Islam says about almighty God
about Allah about Muhammad Islam about
all other Messengers about the when they
are going to stop conveying this message
to the non-muslim brothers and sisters
the prophet sallallahu Islam said Allah
will stop accepting their duas from them
so this is so important for us to
understand the entire mission of
Muhammad always ask the people why
waslam troubled was he troubled because
he's making fight time Salah no was it
troubled because he said we shall smile
in a polite way no was it troubled
because he had a particular hairstyle no
he was troubled by the enemies when he
said I want to propagate this today we
don't want to do this job and Allah is
saying I will protect you if you do this
job the majority of the ummah today has
decided we will be protected if we don't
do this job
so this is absolutely very important for
this ummah at this period of time to
realize that if I commit a sin
individually individually I seek Allah's
forgiveness I say Allah forgive me I
have committed to sin but dhamma is an
obligation on the ummah not doing dawa
the entire ummah is sinning now enter
ummah will have to repent not just
repent they will have to correct their
way and start doing the rights and
obligation on the ummah you meet all
Scholars from every background
unfortunately with all due respect
there are millions of the Quran today
unfortunate most part we have Arabs who
memorize the Quran the Quran is in their
own Arabic language in their mother
tongue so many ayat with which begin
with say to them say to them say to them
say to them o you people of the book o
you Jewish brothers and sisters or you
Christian brothers and sisters
for a common term as between us and you
Allah that we worship none but Allah
we associate none with Allah
we do not take from among ourselves
anyone has our Lord or our pattern but
if they turn back say to them bear
witness be Anna Muslim I am a Muslim
this is number 64. and you know at
number 65 Allah is saying to us Muslims
say to them
Ibrahim oh you people of the book oh you
Jewish brothers and sisters or your
Christian brothers and sisters why do
you fight with the Muslims about Abraham
what is your argument to put forward
about Abraham
the tawrah and the angel were revealed
only after Abraham So for anybody to be
a Jew the Torah has to be there for
anybody to be a Christian the Angel the
gospel the Bible has to be there and
Allah is saying at the time of Abraham
there was neither Torah nor injil so
what was the religion of Abraham
do you not Ponder what was the religion
of Abraham of course he was a Muslim of
course every Prophet Jesus Moses David
Solomon all of them were Muslims we meet
them on day of judgment to ask them what
was your religion they will say our
religion was to submit our will to Allah
this is a statement of English submit my
will peacefully to almighty God in
Arabic the word is Muslim for it yes so
to say primarily dawa is not done by the
Tongue I totally disagree Allah also
disagrees even if somebody argues and
says okay the actions are more important
I'm not here to debate
but to say that by tongue Dharma is not
done primarily it's totally wrong they
can be one or two primary things
according to me it's the most important
no one can ever disagree
that dawa should not be done by tongue
it's the first time I'm hearing this
that somebody's saying that
so so here we have Dr Zakir Naik who's
talking about this let's see what he has
to say I was impacted by Sheikh did that
to say this that these tactics do not
convert hundreds and thousands of people
is totally wrong because I can give
shahada personally more than 200 people
directly I know who have accepted Islam
because of that so how can you say that
these tactics do not convert hundreds
and thousands of people
how can you say that
I'm sure the brother may not be aware of
that so what was Zakir Naik what was he
saying here because he was linking it
back to ahmedat hundreds of thousands of
people coming to the dean one person was
saying no that he hasn't even had I
think one person or something like that
or he knows of it's it's more through
the action so it's like a little debate
here what did you have to say for what
doctor
uh basically uh Eddie I think the other
person was Yasir khazi I mean he's
popular here and I know that
unfortunately a few months back or maybe
during the lockdown period and it was a
nice I mean they're friends so I know
it's a nice you know interaction back
interaction everybody is a specialist of
a field you have doctors you have
engineers and then if you have doctors
in the medical field you have and you
have an eye specialist uh you have a
throat specialist maybe you have a heart
specialist so specialization is the norm
of our society today so in that scenario
Mario if you are doing some work and
trying to say this is Ultimate and the
other work is not important that doesn't
make sense number one secondly see what
Zakir NAX says or what Yasir khazi says
or what Imran says or anybody says we
know as Muslims it is of no importance
in Islam what Allah and Muhammad Islam
says is ultimately important yes so if
you are going to say that dawa is not
important how will you explain the four
ayat of Surah Rahman the first foreign
the most gracious give you the knowledge
of Quran
he created mankind Bayan and he taught
mankind the power of Bayan Bayan is the
only Power humans have been given
unlike other creatures what is Bayan see
every creature communicates but we have
the power to explain our communication
so Allah wanted that the the best
attribute of Allah is
and the best knowledge is the knowledge
of the Quran best of creation is mankind
the best feature he gave to mankind for
what to talk about this message convey
this message and then how how would uh
or anybody of his like or similar to his
ideology uh explain the hadees of
Muhammad sallam from his last number
3461 where the Prophet sallallahu Islam
said
Ayah propagate the message
if even if you know one thing about my
religion about me and he is specifying
that those present here shall propagate
this message to those who are not
witnessing this event or were not
witnessing me witnessing the Quran being
revealed to me so it's a duty so many
ayat in the Quran
say to them o you disbelievers so Allah
is saying what does whole mean whole
doesn't mean actions means speaking
speak yeah speaking
about 300 times what these words have
been used in the Quran they say so you
say they say so you say sing saying
saying there were so many people whom
Muslim went and spoke to them about
Islam so if you are going to say this is
not correct your actions are important
so yes
100 actions are very impressions are
very important yes you can have good
manners absolutely absolutely absolutely
but to say only because of this somebody
is going to accept Islam this is
something I would say insane we would
say we would respectfully disagree
respectfully disagree and to be very
honest see sometimes a person of a
certain level cannot speak such things
to deviate the masses you can't do that
you can't afford to do that you know
Quran you understand Quran in Arabic
also I mean person like brother is of
course he is a very learned man of
Arabic language he reads the Quran he
reads the adhis he knows the life he has
given I think on sirat also episodes so
not to say that dawa is not important I
can't believe uh that a person of his
caliber is going to speak this this
really is a very hurt inshallah he can
make an adjustment inshallah I wish I
was just been here or at least he puts
the point clearly maybe he wanted to say
something else and it got interpreted in
a different way so I wish that my
brother does it so that people
understand that dawa is very important
very important is
the job of every Prophet every Prophet
was sent to 2000 so we wanted to clear
that up because we're talking about dawa
before we give dawah to Elon Musk and
how are you going to give it through
action if we're not used if we're trying
to like unless he's got the Muslims
around him right yes so now we want and
then you and the Uber giving the Uber
driver dawa through words right through
logic to reasoning through uh the human
connection yes so now we want to clear
this up because there might be some
people out there you know who are on
this mindset like just be quiet and just
just say thank you yes sir and let them
figure it out on their own absolutely
see that popular saying that it's not
the activeness of the Rascals that
spoils the society it's the inactiveness
of the good people that spoil the
society so when you find in a society
something wrong is happening to anybody
whether it's happening to the Muslims to
the non-muslims it's the duty of the
people of knowledge to stand up to talk
about the injustices in the best way
without putting themselves in trouble
with without putting others in trouble
see you can speak the truth in many ways
but what is wisdom wisdom is speaking
the truth in a manner that neither you
get into trouble nor other people get
into trouble that is wisdom that is
hikmat that is what Allah said
invite the people to the way of Allah
with wisdom yeah so truth is spoken in
one of the best ways that is possible by
you is wisdom from Allah inshallah and
we can address this also with wisdom you
know with kindness towards our brother
to inshallah like you were saying
hopefully this can be a means of
clarification a lot of evidence is here
a lot of proofs this is a pretty
straightforward it's not something
that's absolutely absolutely you look at
the IELTS from the Quran the Hadith
absolutely the life of the Prophet saws
very important point I would also like
to convey uh Eddie because it should not
get miscommunicated yeah see people like
see none of our intentions is that we
shall Force somebody to embrace Islam
that is against the Quran itself we can
never do that Allah said in Surah number
two act number 256
there is no compulsion in religion Allah
their religion is your religion is to
you and my religion is to me so two
things are very important about these
two ayat one part is very clear you
absolutely cannot force anybody to
become a Muslim you cannot
use money to bribe somebody to accept
Islam this is not part of the Sunnah of
Muhammad sallam
so you cannot force if we convey they
are impressed by the teachings of Islam
not by me not by the die but the
teachings of Islam and they are ready to
accept Islam we can facilitate their
acceptance of Islam masha'allah but we
can't force them this is one part second
part uh Eddie you must have observed
there are people in our society who say
this okay let's not talk to them they're
religious to us and our religions to us
and they quote the same
the prophet said is the best ayat in the
Quran why it completely speaks about
Allah exclusively about Allah
you shall communicate ayat number 255 if
they disagree still to believe in Allah
then comes there is no compulsion in
religion yes but without saying anything
okay you be as what you are I be as what
I am Islam doesn't allow that even in
Surah
ayat number six is the last ayat it
begins with say to the disbelievers
[Applause]
I do not worship what you worship you do
not worship what I worship I do not
worship what you worship you do not
worship what I worship it doesn't appear
that you are going to worship what I am
worshiping so not to you is your
religion and to me is my religion so we
need to understand that dawa is the most
important thing of a muslim's life and
uh Eddie I think it's a very fair
opportunity for me uh being at the Deen
Show to talk about a hadees of Muhammad
sallallahu Islam recorded in sahil
Muslim Hadith number 7438
said on day of judgment all human beings
will be gathered and all of them will be
standing in one single row and Allah
will command any Angel and say to pull
forward some person a man or a woman
from the Muslim Community and they will
be they will be pulled forward and then
what is going to happen the prophet
sallallahu says Allah will ask that man
or the woman that Muslim man or the
woman who lived as Muslims on Earth who
the people believe to be Muslims and
they died as Muslims being Muslims they
were buried with the Muslim Customs the
Islamic system so now they are there in
front of Allah Allah will ask them what
have you brought today to meet me
so this person is going to say Allah
five times Salah there is no negligence
in it fasting zakat Hajj I did every
good thing that you commanded Ya Allah
see all good actions all good actions
you see good actions he's talking about
all good actions
so Allah again asks that's okay all good
actions are okay
but what have you brought to meet me and
this person again repeats second time
the same thing
then Allah asks see this Hadith is in
other books also from saying Muslim
another the meaning of the hadees from
when you read from all the books this
narration
second time when Allah asked the same
question he repeats the same answer the
third time Allah says isn't it true that
you are nothing from nothing I created
you and he says of course Europe then
Allah says is it not true that I gave
you
the risk that I destroyed for you you
received it completely he says of course
Europe then Allah says is it not true I
give you a spouse with whom you
comforted and the person says of course
Europe
Allah will say is it not true I give
some people around you you ordered them
and they obeyed you and he says again
Allah asks
then what have you brought to meet me no
see Eddie he is talking about Salah song
zakat he's talking about all good
actions but Allah is again asking him
what have you brought to meet me this
person understands now
that he is being asked something else
and he says oh Allah I forgot whatever
you gave me I spent it to make my life
on the earth Allah will say today I
forget you pull him by the face throw
him into Hell Fire
and Prophet ended the Hadith inside
Muslim by saying
this is
you know what was missing in his actions
dawa
he's talking about all good actions
Allah says what did you get for me
Muslim Community is not understanding if
tomorrow Allah asks I say I made Salah
Allah Allah will say it's for you psalm
for you zakat for your community had for
you good to the parents to your family
good to the children to your family you
are good to the society to your
neighborhood
for Allah's Dean what have you done you
were sent to do something that is
propagate this message to the people we
want to convey to the people the message
if Allah opens their heart it is up to
Allah and the slaves of Allah to accept
the truth from Allah it is between them
but my job you know our community most
of the time they waste time you know
what is Illuminati
remain Illuminati the Jal that's fine
you are going to be asked about what you
did when you lived have you done the job
of communicating the message or not so
we are very happy we have massage it so
many Masha Allah so many messages in the
US say no yeah but you know how do we
make our massage a group of Muslims
belonging to a particular school of
thought if they build a Masjid now there
is a competition another group of
Muslims with another school of thought
they shall have a Masjid and what's
happening in these masajid nothing but
unfortunately they are involved in a lot
of good activities of course but I do
not find them any one of them
when you talk to them where is the dawah
is lacking completely lacking so this is
where I think Eddie your Dean Center is
going to fulfill this vacuum completely
inshallah especially you see the youth
they need to get connected with Islam
and building playgrounds in the Masjid I
absolutely don't understand this concept
they they're saying we are attracting
the youth by building playgrounds my
brother this never happened at the time
of mummus Islam the sanctity of the
Masjid and the sacred thought about the
Masjid it will never go into the child's
mind if you really want build the
children to play have it separately the
Masjid is for Allah they say no we want
to attract the children I always ask
them if that would have been giving a
talk why is it that people used to wait
for one hour before his talk because
they expertised in public speaking today
we have so many khatibs many of them are
not expertise in public speaking
techniques then what is the result the
youth are not connected to them
so how can we connect our Muslim youth
the Muslim youth need to be made to
understand that they are not normal
people They are the um
they are not normal people Allah has
made them Muslim because they have a
special role to play in the society it
is them who will lead this to society to
Ultimate peace it is them who will
reflect to the society that
was the most learned most wise most
knowledgeable person on Earth why are
you so good and so good because I am
trying to follow me
this communication has to go loudly not
subtle not quietly our Nabis Allah is
not our may be alone he is the Nabi for
every Jew for every Christian for every
Hindu for every Buddhist for every Jain
for every sick for every atheist is
he's gonna be for Elon Musk
yeah speaking of Elon Musk let's see
what he had to say because we opened up
talking a little bit about him so the
last time he came on the scene he went
back and forth on the Twitter with the
Muslim regarding the Hell Fire and he
talked about something along the lines
that if most people are going to end up
in the Hellfire he wouldn't mind being
there also something like that but then
recently some's come up that he's
actually
talking a different tune so I wanted to
get your action your reaction to this
and how would you invite him give him
some dollars do you believe in like a
god or like a higher power well
something created the universe or the
universe is
you know here how did it come to be
um you could say whatever course the
universe to come to be is God or
you know God's depending on your view um
philosophy I think makes sense is to go
out there and to is to expand
Consciousness so that we're better under
better able to to answer the questions
of like what is the meaning of life what
is the nature of the universe like how
do molecules have Consciousness but
somehow we're from a bunch of hydrogen
gas
to and then an assemblage of complex
molecules like ourselves that can feel
and talk and and think I mean just if
you leave hydrogen out long enough it
starts talking to itself basically it's
what happened here so what do you think
no I mean see this is
trying to understand now that he's
agreeing that there is a power there is
a God who created the universe so this
is where dawa plays the role it is the
it is the duty of the Muslims to explain
to him who that God is who that power is
who created the universe so now it's our
duty to explain absolutely absolutely
through words yes this is not just
actions here right what how can we show
in actions that God created the universe
yeah you gotta go ahead and you have to
talk talk so now go how what would you
say to him now how would you respond to
Elon Musk definitely the see because
he's a knowledgeable person he has some
scientific understanding though he's not
a scientist but the way he has
contributed to the world doing some
things that can benefit the people
around world so similarly we need to
have deep concern for him that will
benefit him here in this world and the
akhira and you see this is the secret of
Muhammad Islam the prophet sallallahu
always willed that people like Abu Bakr
siddiq usmani
um
people who are influential in the
society shall become Muslims and that
will be a great support to the cause of
Islam masha'allah so those Brothers I
would congratulate my Muslim brothers
who are in contact with him through
Twitter or whatever means possible for
them now it's the duty of the Muslim
Community who can go approach him talk
to him to set up meetings with Experts
of the field of dawa to talk to him
about it masha'allah and I think I would
suggest that you take an interview with
him and that would be really wonderful
mashallah so it's see when you are
speaking you have a background of dawa
so it's not just that you ask questions
or interview somebody you also keep
conveying The Message of Islam to them
so I think if Elon Musk is given the
right book in his hand made to read this
book directly the book will do the job I
always tell the people you see Allah
made the job so easy for us
maximum you have to do is convey this
message the remaining Allah's message
will do what would you do if you if you
have because to get a sit down with
someone like this to get one minute
let's say you had one minute less than
two minutes to go ahead and talk with
him what would you throw at him what
would you say to him to go ahead and
plant some kind of seed what would you
say I would just ask him one thing I
would say see Elon you are so sensible
person just tell me one single thing a
person who lived 1450 years back in a
desert historical records are saying he
doesn't know how to read and write
Prophet Muhammad didn't know to read and
write you go to Encyclopedia Britannica
to search about him any other historical
record it's very clear he didn't know to
read and write the Quran testifies the
same Suraj number two Surah number 157
my Prophet is an Umi he's an unlettered
Prophet so I would like to ask a person
of that caliber of Elon Musk that how
can this person 1450 years back talk
about the big bang that you're talking
about now can science and religion
coexist
probably not
how can it be possible that
a person living in desert where there is
no water
scarcity of water miles they travel to
get water he's talking sorry Ambience
do not the disbelievers look at the
heavens and the sky
we joined we they were joined as one
single unit of creation the nebula and
we clothe them Ascender and then Allah
says
we created every life from water the
size agrees to it can you imagine a
person who is totally unlated is talking
about it so there are so many ayat in
the Quran that will connect Elon Musk
and he he will be pondering because he's
a man of science yes
absolutely there is a book by Morris
bukail yeah who who
came forward to say there are more than
700 ayat of the Quran out of the 6000
Plus ayat in the Quran at least one
thousand he said deals with modern
science and of them 700 plus ayati said
the science has agreed them to be fact
what does it mean at the time of prophet
Muhammad nobody knew about it that
knowledge didn't exist about those
subjects but 700 of them today this tend
to be true not a single scientific error
in the Quran so this is what Elon Musk
shall be
I talked with and maybe I mean it
depends because one minute two minute
that you get it also depends upon his
interaction with us it's very difficult
to say what exactly we are going to
speak to him it totally depends upon
what mood he has at the time yeah so you
have to reflect with that mood
anticipate with that mood and then talk
to him on those lines Which pull his
interest masha'allah yeah that would be
a starting point how this is what you
would go ahead and leave him with to
think about absolutely absolutely and
hopefully if he looks into the life of
Thomas you sent to mankind if he's
sincere absolutely looking for the truth
he's asking the Creator to guide him
Allah
and we shall also pray for him yeah see
because Elon Musk Jeff Bezos it's Bill
Gates these people they have done so
much for the society they have been so
much really good for the society but
have you seen that a lot of times people
like him he talks about in his early
years he was a Christian I think his
mother father Jewish Christian and then
he went towards that Avenue as a child
but he saw some things that he'd agree
with yeah also the way of Jesus that was
presented to him a lot of times
yes this position human being rejects a
human being being as God Brad like a
whole bunch of religious books including
the Bible and I'm like there's a bunch
of things now that I'm teaching at
Sunday school you know God Church
changes his mind
from the Old Testament to the New
Testament I'm like whoa that's pretty
vengeful in the Old Testament so now
what if he comes into Islam looks into
Jesus is rolling in Islam that we love
Jesus he's a mighty messenger just like
Abraham Moses all the other Messengers
but they weren't Gods
absolutely this would fit this would
make sense absolutely see if for a
person like him he's a person of
reasoning yeah so he would reason that
if God is becoming human then he's
leaving all the characters of a God yeah
because if a man converts to a dog
then he leaves all human characters in
him if a man converts to a dog if I put
it this way technically put it this way
if a man incarnates as dog yes then that
dog incarnate the man incarnate as dog
will leave all the qualities of human
beings yes once it is a dog it's no more
a human being you cannot call it a human
dog yes so similarly if God becomes a
man then God has lost all his Divine
qualities now because those weaknesses
occur in you it's not a God man you
can't be a god you cannot so Elon Musk
is a very reasonable person absolutely
when he finds Jesus is weak Jesus is I
mean sleeping eating see even the Quran
is specifying that part in Surah number
75 and to all our Christian friends out
there this is no disrespect to Jesus we
love Jesus obviously no I cannot be a
Muslim you cannot be a Muslim if you
don't love Jesus we we don't
differentiate between the prophets the
command Quran number two as number 285
we do not the Muslim believers do not
differentiate between any messengers of
Allah but then he goes he goes and kind
of makes a joke you know he's around
some friends and they're talking about
how Jesus saved the party because you
know when they ran out of alcohol and
here comes Jesus peace be upon him doing
his first miracle Jesus was obviously
vertical alcohol you know because one of
his miracles was turning water into wine
yeah that was like they were having a
party they ran out of wine
and they're like let's keep this better
going
he's like I gotcha Okay order that one
yeah and he turns water into wine and he
makes a story out of he goes hey I'll
like save the party I like party on
I mean a lot of Christians do not know I
mean uh when you read the Gospel of John
chapter number one and two you find that
Miracle of Jesus where there was a party
and there was wine served in the party
uh the wine runs over and then mother
Mary she comes and she says uh there is
no wine so first I mean the way Jesus
addresses his mother a woman what have I
to do with you so even as Muslims we
object to it we say no person no Noble
person gentleman will ever call his
mother as o woman so that is one part
that we object to then the second is
where Jesus converts the water into wine
so that's considered the first miracle
of Jesus in the Bible but now when you
see Surah Maryam Surah number 19 at
number 25 onwards when you keep reading
mother Mary delivers Jesus Christ
one more thing there is a complete Surah
in reverence of mother Mary which you do
not find any chapter Mary in the entire
Bible so in Surah Maryam Surah number 19
number 25 onwards Jesus is delivered so
now Allah commands mother Mary to carry
the baby Jesus
that Emmanuel back into the society and
she's worried she says if I am going to
carry him the people will blame me Alex
against me because I have given birth to
a baby without getting married to any
man no man has ever touched me so Allah
says if they ask you any question about
the birth how did you give birth to a
baby without getting married or
something like this if they put an
allegation upon you just point towards
the baby you don't speak anything now
that's the first miracle in the Quran
is surprised she says to the baby yes
and she goes back the people ask her
what have you brought with you your
father was a noble person your mother
was a modest woman what does this that
you are carrying with you she just says
ask him and they ask a baby in the
cradle and the moment they say this
Jesus starts to speak he says I am East
Side memoriam messenger of Allah I am
Jesus the son of Mary defending his
mother's honor defending his mother's
honor the first miracle in the Quran he
defended his mother's honor not saving
according getting people drunk oh no no
absolutely not absolutely not no so Elon
Musk would actually probably relate more
even now defending his mother mother
that was the first miracle of Jesus
defending his mother
how do you like that one huh look at
that kid I was like I had this
existential crisis and I was trying to
figure out what's the meaning of life
he used to point this out he used to say
if somebody got himself himself is
incarnating how would God turn water
into wine water is Purity and wine is
impurity yeah and then we don't have to
talk about all the impurity in the sense
that in it it when it intoxicates you
you are in an inebriated condition and
you are out of your senses you don't
know what you're doing and we don't have
to talk about the list of murders and
raids yes Wars and all the things that
are happening because of alcohol
the health disasters you know what I
mean now that are happening it's
absolutely when you read uh the book of
this compiled by the scholar
in volume number three he quotes the
hadees of mohammi comprises where the
Prophet sallallahu said that alcohol is
the mother of all evils yeah and you see
the FBI statistics today the maximum
rapes that take place on dates are under
the influence of drugs or intoxication
yeah so it's a very serious domestic
violence maximum type times it is
because of getting intoxicated a lot of
time that children being I mean tortured
by the parents at home molested rape all
that stuff incest all this stuff
absolutely so we can never imagine Jesus
forget Jesus being The God Who converted
water into wine and then all of this
stems back to that an excuse for people
to drink right and and a lot of people
who drink they give that excuse well
Jesus converted water into wine yeah
God would not go ahead yeah and open
that door what is all this evil now and
what is the message in the Quran for
alcohol sorry number five number 90
or you Muslims
verily intoxicants gambling divination
by arrows as
the science of knowing the future what
you what you refer as astrology
astrology worshiping the Idols are the
dirtiest work of the Satan do not go
near them
so Allah cursed all these things alcohol
is of course one of the filthiest things
yeah
so you're going to actually have uh
insha Allah God willing when we get the
dean's Center up and running let's talk
about this dawah chorus that was started
by Ahmad we touch upon this yes and also
it was put together by Dr Zucker Nike
yeah yeah so that's the tower course
that people would have to travel before
to India and many scholars even from
madin students of knowledge they I heard
they used to go take this course but
it's the first time actually it's going
to be brought to the USA I think uh
mashallah we have been conducting two uh
at our office iref for about several
years yeah and our Focus see this this
course is basically it doesn't involve a
lot of teachings uh of Fick or anything
else
it is more about making a person a good
public speaker an effective public
speaker
so we try to make our Muslim brothers
and sisters effective public speakers so
that they don't shy to speak about Islam
they if they are introvert so then they
shall come out of that feeling of
introverteness and start talking
positively about Islam try to clarify
the misconceptions answer allegations
and also make sure that if there are
elements in our own Community because of
whom we are getting bad name for Islam
we are bold enough we make a loud
voice to curb their evil actions too so
that's what we actually train and of
course inshallah I think if this could
happen in the USA it would be something
very wonderful now it's a challenge for
you Eddie it's a challenge for American
Muslims here it's a 21 days course
basically 21 days 21 days they gotta
start sending us uh you can contact us
and see there's actually yeah
after the interviews
anybody yes people who are serious yes
yes
that's that's what uh we can really plan
and it's going to be wonderful I mean
your Center is going to have it as a
signature course uh for your Dean center
mashallah it's wonderful always to be
with you and always to talk with you
about so many things
accept our efforts and help us always to
make people understand the truth about
Islam in the most peaceful and academic
manner in Charming thank you very much
it was a pleasure having you guys
and thank you guys Tuning In Here Today
Show subscribe if you haven't already
hit that notification Bell continue to
tune in every week and we got a gift for
you free copy of the Quran just visit
the deanshow.com continue
to support us here and we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you
if one person accept Islam because of
you because of your effort it's worth
more than holding you this is your
brother from Dallas Texas I'm here in
support of the dean center it's a
beautiful organization
in the U.S and they have purchased a
piece of land and several building on it
and we are counting our brother and
sister throughout the US throughout the
world to be part of this magnificent
project it doesn't matter how much you
give it doesn't matter how much you
donate what matter we all participate
inshallah may Allah bless you thank you
so much
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedineshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
and if you like this episode of the dean
show like this video share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work thank you for tuning in peace be
with you assalamualaikum